and hello hello hello everybody I
believe we've officially got all the
buttons for us everything that I'm going
and let's get to it what's good everyone
I'm just trying to keep an eye on make
sure everything is running well make
sure we're all good all the right things
are intact
and it looks like we're okay now so
what's going on everyone hope you're
having a great day
it is Wednesday right we're halfway
through the week now and Amazon Game
Studios has released a crucible which is
actually what we're checking out today
thanks for tuning in again of course let
me just pause these video replays in the
back to make sure everything is smooth
and hello what is good kitty I me oh
snap kitty Arnie's in the chat well
hello how's it going how's it going
chill and speedy and yo Bo and blue eyed
and everybody in the chat how's it going
so yeah honestly all I've done so far
with this game is I've seen the trailers
I've seen some videos we even have some
videos up on the website and on our
Channel right now gamespot.com that kind
of has a little bit of insight into this
game as well but aside from those videos
I'm still going in a little bit blind
here but it's all good let us so one
thing to know is that this game is
free-to-play I've downloaded it on to
steam but it is downloadable or should
be downloadable soon on Amazon because
this is their game you know so if you
had issues trying to get to it through
the Amazon
site then you could possibly try
downloading on Steam instead because
that worked for me and everything went
well
let me also alright
sorry needed to make sure we saw the
chat so yeah you guys do Bob Jones
welcome back us on hello Wyatt
Eric everybody David with the desk ok so
all I've done is a tutorial and now I'm
just gonna hop into some match made
games but there's a lot of really cool
characters in this game and the one that
I use in the tutorial here is summer she
kind of gives me a raise vibes from
Valerie a little bit a little bit of a
lousy vibes to with like the hair and
she's just super badass but she's all
about like the flames she could spin
around with you know like the soul of
magma spiral she's like spinning in the
flame she kind of goes into the air a
little bit it's really cool
but here I am interested in trying I'm
gonna print up all these names wrongs I
know a Jonah Oh Jonah the oceans
Whisperer she's cool because she has
equipment you know she has like this
grappling hook that seems like it's
maybe something along lines a Pathfinder
I'm shells also has these little mines
that follows a target and explodes and
slows so maybe you know like malzahar
from League of Legends
you know he has those little minions
that follow you maybe something like
that and she also has a device that jams
detection and then you can also detonate
it so if you look over here on the Left
all these characters when they level up
within a match get more buff and so you
know this might not do damage at the
start but I level three or one of these
levels Oh at level two actually which is
even better at level two this thing will
actually inflict damage and
people back so everybody over time is
gonna get even more powerful which is
pretty crazy I still have not played
matches so we'll have to see how this
unfolds but I'm just gonna let you guys
see a little bit of all these characters
I still have not had a chance I just
downloaded this guy's we are fresh out
of the box right now still got a new car
smell and everything this looking really
really interesting so far really cool
from the tutorial and from what I've
seen in like videos it has like you know
League Legends vibe you power up and
level up ready go get ready for action
to help level up by killing minions new
stuff and then there's also a greater
objective against other players so let's
just mm-hmm let's start with Jonah Oh
Jonah real quick what was the download
size this is free to play and the
download size for me on Steam was like
13 gigs I think so and it also has
controller support but I'm gonna give it
a whirl
on mouse and keyboard we'll see how it
goes that's what I did in the tutorial
it didn't feel too crazy so yeah I don't
have someone this is my first game so
I'm sticking with this one that I have a
team hopefully my teammates oh oh
hopefully my mic doesn't play into this
game but I guess we'll find out but yeah
what is up
yeah that is true burna trees
sorry if I said that incorrectly but I
think from what I saw earlier they were
having issues when they because they
were a septum much like a moon or
something specific times and I also
noticed that the page on the Amazon
website is actually no longer up so the
last thing I did read was that it's only
available for a name at the moment so
yeah but it's all good it is free to
play so that is nice is it available on
Xbox or Playstation to be honest I'm not
100% sure because the only downloads
that I saw when I was trying to download
it was on Steam and it was listed on the
Amazon website so I would only assume
you could download it from the Amazon
website at some point in time hopefully
we could find a matched actually
I'm pretty confident that we will I mean
it's free to play if you guys want to
download and search with me maybe we'll
match up and learn this game together
[Music]
I don't know if it's available on Mac
because I'm using PC I mean I guess
while I wait I can well I don't want it
click outside the game because I want
you to hear this music the music is
actually pretty nice
looks like an apex and destiny 2 had a
baby I can see that but when you start
when you see the gameplay in the match
you're not going to think that at all
for sure if it is I think classified a
shooter but from what I saw so far it's
definitely more I don't know how to
explain it it feels very League like to
me just with the way you have to attack
everybody is auto-attacks
different like she has a harpoon summer
she has like a flamethrower which can be
different ranges depending on which
skill tree you decide to go into because
that's another thing I don't know if I
can switch from here so you do have to
commit to the character that you pick at
the beginning before you go in so let me
just cancel this real quick because I
can choose here how I want my character
should evolve right so I should think
about this so earlier when I was looking
at her I want to do this cuz this
increases the range that the mines will
go when they're chasing someone and it
gives me an extra moon so I actually
want to start with that and then over
here I think I was think yes this one
increases 10% speed when the jamming
shroud when you're within the I guess
the aura of it including your allies
which actually sounds amazing because
that extra bit of speed could go a long
way these other two was like you know
you apply in the targa if you get
critical hits which I don't doubt that
one is amazing but that also relies on
me to get a critical hit so I'd rather
go for something a little more safe that
might be better for the team and then
the last one I think I want to leave it
here yeah although this increases the
damage
four critical hits quite a bit which is
amazing which tells me she might be
really deadly in the hands of a really
really good sniper I don't know we'll
check it out I have not fired with this
character at all but I'm gonna go with
this one because I felt like them being
slow and us being fast could only mean
better thanks for me so now that I've
said it didn't save oh no how do i oh I
hit space to confirm okay so I had this
one and that one it's high tide alright
and I've hit space alright it's still
there okay alright make sure you confirm
it when you go in there that's one thing
it looks fun well I've done the the
tutorial mode only so far so it's
definitely really interesting hmm
I'm but that's all I've done so I want
to see how it is against everyone or
against other players or whatever I feel
like it's gonna take a lot of
communication though if they ever do
something you know high-level with this
you know
the battle pass yes you're right can i
browse while searching it looks like I
can alright so free pass
preseason ends in 53 days I don't own
the battle pass actually but let's take
a look at what's in here so captain
Mendoza snowbound skin interesting we've
also got some bonus xp Prima's a blade
pod a suitable vehicle for her first
blade so that's interesting my gosh it's
a knife through
okay so we got some emotes some boy
signs I'm not exactly sure what that pod
was though she's super cool though she's
heard for Alaba credits all right that's
the in-game currency I would assume we
also have 50 season one battle stars
some decals raisins fries so that was
just Tier one there's ten tears here
[Music]
cute oh yeah this Skiles is its own
character - there really it's like they
have some adorable designs in here for
sure
see I'm gonna see more skin so here we
go very nice
can i it won't let me like drag it oh
okay we're joining a game we'll return
to the battle paths after this game but
finally we're we're in it we are gonna
do this how does the game volume sound
on you guys is everything sound okay let
me know
[Music]
I mean it's still new it's like it
literally just came out today so we will
see how it goes
find the hive defeat the hive and cat
okay so we have to get three parts so we
could also steal hearts from other
people right it's like the Baron
see that I'm gonna draw too many too
many elements other games but let's
check it out
oh snap
upgrades okay these are my the things I
selected oh you can change them in the
detail all right that's cool
Oh No
in coming events
gosh oh look at this map okay and then
the green is where your ally is picking
pain
oh I think we all have to pick a
different drop point or in I'm learning
right now as we go move swiftly okay so
my name is Mikey Angeles good mines is
increased okay so she basically told me
when I selected which is nice
confirmation so with summer which is a
character I was almost okay so we gotta
kill these guys
and this blue stuff is what we need to
collect so
see she has a little look here which is
really cool actually so we kind of just
have to be no fights guy I feel like my
sensitivity is a little high about in a
rock out with a very little while I
would only assume that eventually that
eventually will actually be running into
the other team obviously can't tell us
this area so my hook Oh a nice little
flip has like 10 second cooldown wait
people shooting at us let me not forget
there's like a detecting mode oh ok so
there's a harvester that gives essence
over time over there and then we can see
okay so I wonder how we can pain the
harvester for if there's a pain the Z is
peeing another play notes that said like
an emo area how fart is my England going
that's not a bad length actually okay
okay so let me try wait wait wait I hit
my squid I'm supposed to let see or not
there's only work against human or do I
have to reactivate it maybe I just
wasn't close enough to him I don't want
to get too far from my teammates so stay
over here that's the other thing to you
right it's like on the move who's heals
who's got healed interaction shoes
[Music]
interaction feels okay let me get over
here are two men over there kind of are
is this purple stop hurting me
we definitely need to do this
let's see there's only one person at a
time your ally own the Syst Harvester
okay so let's search is there another
one is that your next one closest to us
I don't know we'll find out let's see so
I'm trying to see on my on my actual
screen I'm not seeing too many drops but
on my exploit I am seeing that it is a
little bit choppy yeah it does look a
little choppy I will try to fix that in
a second if it doesn't fill out on its
own I'll try to see what's going on let
me see if I can do that real quick yeah
that's so weird it's not lagging on my
let me just it just do that and see okay
Oh No oh crap
Oh champ the shield every low oh I'm
scared okay oh okay I lied right there
for sure for sure okay so they were over
here attacking the high
no numbers detected inside the container
oh no gotta go oh that did not take me
where I know okay
sorry I was trying to fix the settings I
don't know if it's any better actually
bad okay so alright I'm assuming we've
lost that oh it's still going actually
this before Orson okay this is a little
bit better
do I keep my okay I'm still a level 200
G is skills yeah
so G to heal you can also pick up
stick-up health packs why is there
somebody I say fall damage no I don't
think so I'm really far for me see we
got a monster here
those orange things actually make you
invisible oh no oh no oh crap I'm stuck
okay so I think okay after her the
squizzle
the only work on actual opponents I
thought they might work on the minions -
yeah let me get to my team because
they're really far the heart can be
captured did we get it no I'm you know I
think I messed up I think I was supposed
to choose a more optimal landing
position because I know at the beginning
they gave us that option ah I am so far
the Sarah wait of run this hook oh no oh
no
oh she's invisible Oh No
your opponents have captured a high part
crap oh god no okay so I don't think
this character okay so I can choose my
yeah that's what I miss out on doing
last time
okay interesting I think I think
whoever's a really good sniper will
carry you and your allies now more
faster when near your jammer
oh okay so I've leveled up manat or so
that's something actually have not
thrown my camera
but let's so I have on this eight okay
I'm not see these are the Med unity
tried to that let's see
thing
the last one for inside the container
here we can level up a bit more
- have - oh crap just kind of use it
like Pathfinder Missy I guess I don't
get that essence unless I walk over oh I
thought that was like a bubble oh no
crap this minions gonna world
the hive is over here oh no they're
destroying it I think
Oh No are they waiting for us it's just
the bait they're just kidding
must go must okay nice I covered some
distance there
okay so the house is here right my baby
Oh No Oh No
right there oh they win the super far I
think only one person can pick a spot
actually we all can drop on the same
area okay
yeah I mean so getting used to the hood
I think I'm only in level 3 still yeah
so I should be killing some of these oh
okay
aha I see so these purple things I get
it I get it
if I got like mad minions on me or
something I could just hit that purple
thing and I'll probably do damage
everybody walking in that area where is
that weirdest I was like where's ah ah
it unlocks in one minute but they
already have two hearts so oh okay okay
with him
hives just keep spawning until someone
gets three I'm assuming okay that's kind
of cool
wait can I hide and wait see if I would
turn invisible oh oh no I didn't want
that but that actually went further than
I thought it would somebody up there
oops my things over there my bad team my
bad oh no chopper chopper
oh shoot
I miss every time I'm bad
oh crap he's like a machine gun
I'm the worst I'm the worst oh she's in
physical stompers good I still feel like
I didn't know what is this
let's forget unlimited ammo oh my
goodness like do I even know how to lead
a shot apparently not not so
AHA there we go I finally used it I was
like I don't think I've had a chance
crap crap
oh my gosh I landed like one hit
I'm like Widowmaker except I don't know
if my aimed down shots do as much damage
but okay okay
besides me and not being able to land
any of those shots it was kind of fun oh
they're so kind instead of being like
you lost they're like your team play
second have they mentioned a console
release or just PC as far as I know I
think it's just PC for the moment it is
free to play
okay so let's return to the lobby she
was cool I need to get good before I can
and go in with her I think she's gonna
take a very skillful person to make it
used to her just cuz you know sniping is
hard um right so there's a ton of other
really cool character so it seems like
this guy yeah he has knuckle duster
laser beam attack generates small amount
of shields ooh fires laser for piercing
damage that's cool so I would assume if
that's like in the team comp II just
mercs the shields and then everybody
else's needs to like finish the deal
maybe this guy each also has ax
increases rate of fire over time
misty is the name of this gun increasing
turbo fire turbo fire increases fire
rate of time that's cool rock it forward
at high speed ooh
drink a refreshing beverage to
immediately restore health okay so he's
kind of like road hog knock enemies back
and block projectiles in immediate area
this guy sounds really cool we might
have to try him out there's a lot of
cool characters yeah so this guy also
has a gun you know he might be the
classic soldier 76 and he's got a sprint
you know classic Cod character Supply
Drop flash grenade improve hold to
improve rifle accuracy yeah it's
basically soldiers own musics you come
she's cool she's like she rains fire on
everyone okay so let's see genius Tosca
all right she definitely gives me rumble
vibes fires a scattershot of acid
bullets short-range teleport in the
direction of movement passes through
obstacles ooh
create a smoke screen which disrupts
enemy detection and blocks line-of-sight
immediately detect all opponents within
50 meters in front of you ooh
that's a really good one actually that's
pretty cool
explosive compound inflicting damage and
slowing her okay for my Prima she looks
super cool shoot and swing fire your
pistol and attack with your sword
nice toggle between oh so she's got some
sword stance moves faster okay
so you know obviously get your knife out
you run faster create still not blocks
enemy attacks okay so and prevents
enemies from crossing so it's like a
bubble shield but they can't even enter
the dome that's interesting
Paolo shields the place of force field
that deflects projectiles and blocks
melee okay
is that like she like hold stuff okay
I'm assuming disrupting strike aim down
sights and sword stance unleash an
energy wave that disrupts opponents in
pistols amps aims down sights cool I
gotta see what this little robot does Oh
bug you're so cute alright spray damages
opponents and activates plants thrusters
propelling you forward and vertically
you your seed pods your plants and
nearby Alex allies gain a temporary
overage shields nice creates a slowing
and damaging AoE beneath you crop crop
this that is so funny oh my gosh okay
fires a speed pods that can be activated
by spraying okay so you know a little
bit of cyber action also gives me some
wall-e vibes which I love
now this is literally if like wall-e and
Eva had a baby and their baby with my
voice this is though he's a Drac --all
she's got a big ol axe chop strike with
vibran axe
- in the direction your camera's facing
you become enraged choose between
life-stealing claw tack arranged crab
attack woohoo interesting that sounds
pretty cool but he has life steel which
sounds very useful I mean I doubt he has
a long-range thing I don't think that
grab is probably that large of a range
but I guess we'll see um your axe hums
with power choose between spinning a
spinning dota area attack or a stunning
area attack okay sonic pulse fine fire a
sonic pulse from your axe all right so
you know what let's try to give everyone
a shot here we'll start from the
beginning source so we kind of had a
rundown of what all of them kind of do
oh oh well they let me change the tree
in the start so from what we read so far
this is like you know the soldier 76
type the straight up site like the ryu
so to speak they want to ease you into
it
so yeah let's start with him we'll work
our way through how are you guys doing
though thank you for letting me read
through all of this because I feel like
when it comes to games like this that
are coming out they really make oh
actually I think they do have an arcade
mode so you guys let me know do you want
to see more of the heart of hives the
multiplayer modes or do you want to
check out this arcade I haven't played
in either arcade but I did see that
there was an option for that in the menu
so let me know because that might speed
up the process of trying out all these
characters also but when we play online
we get to see other people use these
characters too so we'll see all right
I'm gonna edit my skill tree here in the
beginning this looks well made so far I
mean I'm enjoying it so far it seems
pretty in-depth they've given the
characters a lot of tools they've given
us already
you know a variety of ways to use these
characters in terms of the skill tree
and stuff at the beginning so I'm
actually liking it so far
so we'll see okay cool
so after this match we'll hop over to
the to the arcade and check it out you
know we'll get get a feel for these for
this heart of the hiya 4v4 let's see who
they've got all right
we have one of the guys with the axe
alright so let me choose my upgrades
here is this rifle shots are 25% faster
between 5% less damage all off place
grenades with 3 mini grenades peaceful
hmm provides a turret I kind of won its
her it I want to check that out
oh no I'm running out of time ETS talk
back
and combat shield regeneration oh I
think I wanted that but it's finite man
I hope it at least saved my trick
because it turns on - you saw it alright
let's do this I have a sprint
oh yeah see this is heck yeah
is it infinite also a alright I'm ready
like this a bit more a little bit more
movement than before you know um a
jhanas movement was with the grapple
which wasn't bad actually
there was a few times I hit a good a few
good corners and it took me pretty far
so let's go kill some stuff okay so
let's test out this Supply Drop this
terrific right let's see that with love
Wow oh they did draw and ajapa med Oh
oh I see oh wait there's so many
let's roll oh crap
I put the turret facing the wrong way I
wonder if I can rotate it I suppose it's
fine I get another one in 20 seconds
she sees guys down Oscar Mike
oh no I see me over there it does not
look like he's very healthy
see this is summer she's one I was using
in this tutorial
ah I'm burnin she's pretty cool my
around and be damaged oh oh no no I'm
burning I'm burning we gotta go I'm
chasing her if I can
oh no that's not gonna happen folks oh
my goodness I'm so bad I'm so oh all
right ain't afraid of fun close let's go
there
dang she was so low that's fine five
seconds I didn't look to see if my stun
grenade doesn't meet him or not but I
should have thrown it out there anyways
because I had it
maybe the true it wasn't the wave it's
okay though I have a spring so Wow yeah
it's great
all right so my supply job is back I'm
gonna throw my e over there and see what
happens
just flash it up here oh I thought this
was my teammate
no tonight oh it does do damage okay
that's nice to know
I'm gonna die though music
Oh No let me round you so much
okay there's mine oh let's go team
I guess we guys will choose that hi I
know it was hot and sweaty over here for
a second we got weird that's what I want
to know I am I am I'm trying at least
okay
so again I need to level up I need to
not forget about that
oh I'm hurting in this thing this thing
hurts that hive is a lot prettier than I
thought it was I thought the purple
stuff of the high of oops - stammers
detective inside of the crab I should
before we go over there feel a little
bit let's roll
incoming second father for me they not
your aim down sights are now faster and
more accurate nice
incoming
apparently I needed it really bad
no come on get over here my goodness now
I see you but Oh Jane wait this vision
of them when they go in nothing
we should probably be careful
like it's not bad boy
the audience's already doing take them
down I sure I think they'd at least help
old one person there all right wait wait
wait any a pay attention bring my mouse
ah okay these are all far your
opponent's have captured a high part our
opponents captain now ready for us
dang okay
well I guess we should try to teammate
needs help
oh there's a lot of monsters here are
they Kenny you know we're just passing
I'm coming to me to save the day ah to
see he's so far no Oh Timmy I'm so sorry
I hope you lived I'm here I'm here
oh oh where did she go I lost her
where's my into my teeny desert okay on
second thought
it's time to go I killed somebody had a
meter let's go turn
okay she went that way which is good I'm
going this way
heel switcheroo stoppers detected inside
the containment barrier
I'm so now if I didn't have a sprint
right now this would be a lot worse back
here
Isaac I'm presently please hmm I'm a
level four I wonder if everyone levels
up equally
the team needs my help
yeah this map is massive ok I'm here now
that would love better whole team all
right we got this one
easy-peasy I showed up 4.2 seconds
harvester master this is pretty fun I'm
not gonna lie
enjoying myself right now
all right so we've tied it up tied it up
all this friend thing is actually yellow
mari let's good welcome back
oops okay they're following me I was
like what's wrong with but I'm leading
the way let's go see everyone's using
their - abilities everyone kind of has
some sort of movement ability oh I see
someone over there oh and my Supply Drop
is ready we're playing it slow those
slugs that I like this we creep in on a
raid Oh
hold er no you don't even know man
really everything's so far away it's
like I haven't had time to properly
enjoy the map yet because I'm like ah
this thing is ten years away and I need
to right
I don't know my teammates are still
following they're all there trying to
get this station
on the move I mean that's where I was
going oh there's someone here
those shops
shots where I'm in
those are my feet I was like I hear
somebody I think oh let's go sir where's
my turret right now
no I gotta go that did not work out as
planned Oh No
No okay the turns didn't do as much
damage when I was
I stood behind fed-up running out in
front of cast your rifle shots now
inflict more damage after reloading oh
all right I needed that I needed that
all right where's the team going oh it's
so far though right here stay on this
side so five is maximum level boots on
the ground boots on the ground no longer
in the grave no level six no there's
definitely more than five levels I was
wrong that was wrong oh we were close to
this one oh no we gotta get him
falling in support
hi guys
oh no oh crap
oh my gosh Mike slip sighs Mike Witt
Michael up sighs oh the heart is still
up for grabs
oh I just oh no or Tina's
your own ins have captured or just set
class abilities it's kind of bull you
can level up you can level up certain
abilities but at the beginning of the
match you can choose your skill tree I
guess because not certain levels you can
choose different things the level up
which is pretty cool I tried to save an
ability before the game started but it
didn't but it would have allowed me to
have more of my ability which is the
grenade which I think would be super
useful but since I did not equip it in
time I got the default selection I did
get the little turret thing that I'm
using in time that's another separate
they'd deployed
he's trying to run but we can good okay
it's always like the last video fight
needs where's the Ohio wipe like where
are we on the hunt
oh what's over there Oscar Mike
but we still have two minutes though
if you look on the left top left this up
two minutes until the hive actually
unlocks so you know it's kind of got
some king of the hill action oh I see
them I see them all right what is I'm
sure I was trying to see what the ping I
don't know what the pain is but it's
fine
I wonder how this feels on controller
because it does have controller support
I feel like I'm Way ahead of ya
oh shoot oh shoot okay running back okay
they're here I don't know how to paint
it so just try to read my mental
abilities incoming
that fools that whole second probably
that clip Rinda Slee oh crap Oh
Oh
oh no oh dang I thought I was running
away from her but she was lying right
there
the heart is expose good luck team
controller support is a must I do play
some games on mouse and keyboard but my
hands a little bit so let's get this
done
no all the the heart's not exposed yet I
don't mean
[Music]
just kidding all right that's fine
that's fine I had four kills that time
I'm pretty sure that's more than one I
had the first game by like four so he's
cool he's definitely like an
introductory character or something to
ease you into a game something familiar
which I think it's necessary in any game
all right let's close this and we wanted
to check out arcade so here's arcade
capture harvesters and defeat foes to
drive your opponents to defeat all right
cool so we'll do that one we'll try this
out since you guys wanted to try it out
so we played with captain Mendoza
you called you guys actually haven't
seen her from my point of view but we
did play against her in the last match
we'll keep going down the list though so
flamethrower range increased creature
struck by flamethrowers drop essence as
they take damage that's probably gonna
be really useful for this arcade mode so
ooh thruster pounce jump while using
fire pole stressors to drop on opponents
drop damaging them and knocking them
back oh I think that a summer from the
last match that Li not that all right
cool so let's see
[Music]
yeah let's just do this one for now
because I think it might be helpful
creates 50% more flaming projectiles and
increases dam and she had that sounds of
using fireballs leave behind a burning
area for four seconds that sounds super
useful too
ignition spark knocks back 50% and
deflects projectiles these are all good
it's hard to just pick one I'm gonna go
[Music]
numb I like this one put burn help
damaged people around hopefully it helps
live longer
okay so let's rock with this layout
that's wrong infirm and let's play this
arcade mode searching okay so it must be
other people in the party what is this
game this is crucible this is Amazon's
new free-to-play
PvP game it is a shooter like a
third-person type shooter um and yeah
it's been good fun so far we played a
couple of the hive game modes I'm
checking out this arcade mode which I
assume means I'm searching for three
people to join me in this arcade
adventure so oh there we go we did it so
we used captain Mendoza and we use a
jhana
so far two very interesting characters
if I were to relate them to any
characters for you guys too
get a sense who are just tuning in right
now captain Mendoza is definitely on the
soldier 76 side and got a jhana more
closer to the Widowmaker side
interesting all around
all right so capture and defend
harvesters defeat enemy hunters then
here did I not select arcade I guess
this is the arcade mode and it has
everyone in it I'm not sure we'll check
again next round but it's nice to at
least see all these game loops okay I'm
summer right oh yeah your teammates can
pick the same character as you it's not
like Balor in your overwatch where it's
character lock one per team look we got
three of these little BOTS
I forgot the boss name I ready but we
got three of those little guys they have
to is there something I don't know is
this character Oh Pete where's everyone
going
I hope I land a great see I can already
tell with a full squat this gave me
really [ __ ] everybody like I'm
dropping here I'm dropping here
summertime is nice so that's great
because we want the essence so that we
can level up faster am i right and the e
pushes back oh yeah this is the weight
we're gonna look we're already almost
level two this is fantastic
now do more damage in the top half okay
so this power up already it feels very
good I'm gonna try to get to so I do
more damage in the upper half of my heat
gauge and my - takes almost a full half
which is a great little what seems to be
a combo set up here potential
yeah look we're already almost level
three oh wait I forgot we have to get
the harvester song I think I hear the
other summer got an enemy over here oh
man
someone's fighting somebody someone
sleeping over here huh oh and made a my
baby thank you
oh I'm overheated as made a mistake oh I
shouldn't have pushed in somewhere oh
okay
is that his poison it's kind of like
twitching you're definitely getting this
game hey my a stray dog dream click why
not and I love the fact that there's
more games that are free to play okay
let me level up let me stop messing
around trying to be a head honcho out
here oh did I not properly shoes oh man
oh no there's people here okra oh no
they see me way back over there
okay I see mania Beckham
Oh
sorry we're out of here well I don't
they might see me die the other guy did
I did not notice
oh no answer some people here I don't
know how to pay naturally so
oh we're kindest for it out
I didn't pick a spot yes I do believe it
is only in a absent low number time they
must have had some sort of issues this
morning because I know I was supposed to
lunch at noon and it was well after a
noon before it went up on Steam and then
the Amazon page was like alright I'm
gonna hang around this little robot guy
because you know apparently we got three
of them on the team he must be good at
something I think she's here something
like that which is always great I don't
want to leave him behind come on little
guy he's cute
oh I can't forget about money ease
because it pushes me back just make some
space
I'm almost level flat
oh crap oh no never get close to my
favorites or so far no wait Anita I
think this one's closer do you have the
same player on the other team right now
yeah we have three of this little robot
guy IFRIC I don't know it's exact name
but I think he's a healer oh man is he
just wrapped up Oh kidding oh they're
fighting
[Music]
all right let me stop messing around
No
what the heck Oh am i walking into there
oh this is the guy this is the guy the
one that's every team has so many of
them if you can throw a little seedlings
and you know has this little gas I guess
[Music]
no where's my see you this is horrible
help me okay I saw my teammate over
there oh my goodness
I can get her please reach too far I
don't know where my teammates were fit
that would have been great all right
i'ma spawn right behind our guys there
is controllers support D canteen bug
doesn't actually heal people yeah I
realized that after I saw he was the one
with the little plants I was like oh
yeah I don't think that guy's a healer
uh I tried this once but I still feel so
far all right he's healing he doesn't so
the little turret dudes
oh man Oh is this huh is he dead
I can't tell or is this oh that's my
teammate oops I was like what's damaging
me I didn't know what I was getting
damaged by no team in I do like how the
med kits look
all right oh they're all over there oh
my gosh dang that shot over he didn't
expecting it
ah
oh man
did you die myself
okay all right I lived through some sort
of team play it
oh my god I stood on that for that
budget
can we get some jet action going on here
[Music]
oh man we lost but it's fine
there's only one giant map yeah I I
think that's the case I mean it's a
pretty big map I feel like I haven't
even seen all the parts of the yet but
we've only played like three games so
far so I'm sure we'll get to it
eventually
all right so summer is cool I actually
like her let's check out this little
dude this little dude bug everyone was
using him yes my plan Dash's inertia gun
which applies a stacking slow effect
upon hit recharges weapon energy a clip
shotgun which fires a powerful
short-range burst researches with an
energy tank so she's got a shotgun wool
SMG electro knife huh
okay so she just has a bunch of
different weapons and you just until you
kill everybody got it um so yeah let's
just keep going down the list oh I was
like um kinda road hog like turbo fire
does not deplete below 25 high idle ooh
increases maximum health
that is really good actually increases
maximum ammo by 30 increase amount
shields doubles move and speed when
using blowback vents and increases
duration no 2.5 to 3 seconds flicks
sandwich pinking up fully charges turbo
fire that sounds dude so we're gonna
keep that one
[Music]
all right let's go misty so yeah I guess
that was your acade mode was this
harvester command which was interesting
let's try alpha hunters since I mean
some poor souls gonna get paired up with
me but it's all good at least I'm tanky
wait did the music change to fit him
because he is like the trucker hat he's
got the you know the farmers sure looks
like he's got a little bit of a farmer's
tan going on right there funny yes this
game it did come out today actually so
it's free to play on Steam how does
winning and losing work well it depends
on the mode so some of the modes we were
playing earlier you had to capture you
basically had to like destroy three
hives and capture the hearts but if you
play League of Legends it's kind of like
the Baron if you get it really weak and
the heart is out there then the other
team could come and steal it so and then
the first three hearts wins
there's the mode we just played which
was kind of like territory slash king of
the hill slash yeah you just had to like
hold down all the choke points you know
like domination style I guess and then
this mode I guess is like multi I don't
know which other way to explain it but
it's like two one two one two
- I think so yeah we'll give all of you
subtract we're also trying out all these
characters so
what's up noble welcome welcome how's it
going have I played one game in I've
played three games yet actually
hopefully Earl is top tier is this is
that his official name actually didn't
look for some reason but it sounds
fitting Earl good old Earl
[Music]
it's also interesting too because you
know I've never been super agree at like
the third-person shooters but this one
feels really fun teen defeated make a
temporary alliance no respawning this
could be a short one let's see
all right so I got soldier on my team
this guy's a level 5 this guy's level 10
oh my goodness I'm scared okay
wait my teammate where'd you pick t me
well no I don't know if my teammate went
with me then we'll make it very obvious
like oh hey mr. Feeny's dropping hair or
whatever hopefully okay I got a good
feeling about this whoa whoa whoa how do
I turn this off do I get what the heck
well I just wasted that that felt like
you know a Reinhard - type thing
oh yeah let's get this guy
we got stuck he got stuck yeah let's go
teammate you reload my big ol little gun
permit oh can I not a mite all right I
give up no time to waste
t me where are you wait don't leave me
girl
hard astern master control incoming
I already got one brave and out witches
got some health packs - yeah let's fill
up real quick fill er up
Earl detects can't forget to use the
detects what's this timer noise it
sounded very stressful
what is my eat again oh there's someone
over there there's someone ah there's
someone over here
ha she was tryna hide wait I don't know
if I saw the boy
ah haha she got away ha generation
amplifiers
oh crap
Oh No
this is behind the drop
then he wrote that all the way over
there oh no I definitely was the wrong
way
you kind of rock now he is yeah and you
know now through gives you maximum
travel time
got to use them thank you I did not use
a proper word or a whole I'm taking
damage
there are
that hits the spot you got to use him
head care oh the ring is losing and I
did not realize that there was a ring
there alright I won super far either
so kind of cool oh there's someone here
he was invisible
I don't matter pain I reload my weapon
he was here he was being a semi p1 hmm I
see
Oh any crop-dusted me
okay so he's a quick one I feel like
he's playing some games with us here
there's my teammate
[Music]
Sanders amplifier incoming
so someone's behind us oh okay so that's
what that thing is like what is it
ah
cancel the Rings closing in a little bit
he needs a room
refreshing
oh man Jackie one for me one for misty
Thank You kid
get her out get her all TV please no no
all I needed
Stephen collapsing okay I'm needed sir
to be lodged I believe in the team it's
almost over it this is actually pretty
fun it's a little less of like so
farming right it feels and a little more
and it's pretty quick the way that the
ring of light now this camera view
though is definitely very choppy I
noticed a lot of the elements that
aren't you actually playing and moving
in the game look very choppy let's go
see me helping him get in time on this
dream that sounds talking about yeah
that was [ __ ] me I think I carry but
that was so alright I very much enjoyed
that let's keep it moving I want to try
to check out as many of these characters
I as I can Earl was fun and I love that
his name's Earl Earl was super fun ok
raring to go Aska so oh okay so she has
a blink
you know tracer style she also has the
it's this one with the crop dust cuz
that made me laugh so hard oh no I think
it's this guy with the cross yeah so
buddy
super juice okay increases starting med
kits from one to three maximum make its
capacity three to five that's pretty
cool
okay increases blink distance you're
mainly attack transform it was up to
eighty do tears blink bus booster seeing
school but I think I must yeah I'm gonna
start with that one who decreases med
activation time that's nice scatterfire
increase kickers reduce x-ray gamma rays
increase and you get 360 I might do that
one damages and slows enemy for two
seconds its twenty percent that's pretty
good
no I want vision though give me vision
and then the level of five blinking
leaves behind a bomb that set me it's
after one second yeah that might be the
one
increase from one to three clowns will
be smaller and decreases cooldown which
is this one smokescreen now we'll do
this one because it's supposed to
teleport better I like the way that
sounds
alright I'm gonna stay in this mode
though because this mode was quick and
it was fun hmm well I feel lucky that we
haven't really had any major issues yet
with playing it's been about maybe
anywhere from like a 30-second to a
minute and a half week time which is not
bad but yeah and that's been a few hours
though since the launch so maybe some of
those bugs and stuff have spewed out a
little bit not quite sure but so far
it's been running pretty well for me I
haven't had any major issues but yeah
have some patience yeah I mean I
wouldn't expect right now there being a
lot of
unexpected technical difficulties but
you know I'm sure I'm sure they want
everyone to be able to play this because
they worked so hard on it
[Music]
can't patience but not high hopes hey I
mean maybe that's even better because
then you know if it is disappointing in
your eyes then you know you don't feel
so bad and then if it exceeds your
expectations even better I would say try
it out I mean I'm having a good time so
far actually
this cue is taking a little bit longer
this time around but this is pretty much
the longest one we've had yet I think
let me look at where the battle path
actually because okay so they got icons
and okay so now that we've played a few
I know what these pods are so you can
unlock customized pods that you drop
into the game in which is cool I do like
this color scheme
more credit an emoji some spring I do
not forgotten what okay I'm gonna see
more skin though this is skin okay
Space Lab coveralls pretty
straightforward doesn't look crazy or
like more cars more emos nice
level five decal oh here we go
joining the game yes Michel it is
already up on Steam right now so go
ahead and download it if you want to
give it a truck free to play
[Music]
all right so we are using Tosca now this
is coming soon oh that's weird
maybe refresh but I had to refresh my
store before it showed up because I was
following this page since this morning
and it did say coming soon on my in it
until i refresh the story beyond that my
troubleshooting skills come to an end
all right so I got the big dude with the
ax on my team this round I'm we've got a
lot of people playing Tosca
everybody wants to be tracer here
where's my teammate going oculus assist
bok'nor
allies picking 8 oh no I saw that the
last second I don't think I'm gonna feel
if they see me wait let's create somehow
you know make it thank you Carrie
and then my bling huh that's cool I am
how fast is my blank oops oh no no no no
my god
well that was the end of my run there I
am an my team and I thought they were
behind me I didn't realize we had parted
ways Ari
yes I want to quit I felt like we waited
longer for that match than we did
actually playing in that match I didn't
even get to see what all my abilities
did because I accidentally wasted both
my blinks - - directly into that team
well the I didn't even get me ask you
for that it's all badness um names Tosca
yeah at the ready I just have to hold
that Ellen keep it moving pistol energy
oh yeah we definitely want to increase
our range pistol shots low opponents
[Music]
okay so for this one to switch weapons
is control alright and then create the
dome and then I have a shield
cool I think this is what we want
dang okay heels you and your aliens I am
NOT a valley girl without them if I can
even get up to level five vitamin all
right
I mean maybe one day they'll release it
on console who knows because the
controller support has Xbox icons make
me see if I could show you this
see
so maybe one day
all right so let's try out this
character I'm still interested in trying
out bug just cuz I want to see how that
style plays out planning little
seedlings and kind of you know growing
them and stuff like that
we'll see oh I did a daily challenge
already play as bug or summer maybe
that's why everyone was using bug cuz
they were trying to unlock the daily I
see now I see now all good all good
Oh
looks laggy there's certain moments
where at the a like playbacks like when
I was viewing my teammate from like
death screen
those are pretty laggy but I'm assuming
it's it's like that because I'm watching
but when I'm actually playing I don't
experience any lag I did notice earlier
this stream not exactly
well but I do have the stream settings
on 60fps so but it seems have been doing
well these last few games so we'll see
[Music]
our race we were on like the 50-inch
before that's adorable
Tosca love cute
I kind of want to see you at work skin
oh that's pretty cool
this one's a decal have any more
tomorrow yeah
you just got Mindo xored okay ah di on
there Oh No sad face big tears Summer
Sun is okay joining in let's go my video
is smoother than the key
I wonder oh I thought my Oh
did it is crash
Oh No
oh no it's here woohoo I got scared for
a second I got worried alright
let's see how this one goes shall we
see everyone's kicking
I'm aa
anja I know Joe I forgot her name rarity
like where does it tell me where mighty
me is thinking
I don't know
yep you can play with a controller it
does not produce over I strive for my
prima your sword attached and I don't
have a greater range
and I'm slicing them but I really don't
feel like
[Music]
okay so there's no actual reload it's
more of a man
my teammates struggling with
oh there's an actual person here
I just invested oh I'm at the point they
can't come in here right that was the
that was the agreement
oh that does not last very long no I'm
put inside this is it [ __ ] me
okay okay okay I don't know why I was
expecting the dome to last but uh I
guess that would be pretty okay because
they can't walk into it either
good luck teammate survived or not but
interesting I don't know how we won that
first match we played in this mode but
okay I'm always getting a fill for what
yes I'm bad the robots would say they
were bad all right
didn't get to see the rest of his battle
pass yes saw this page more banners my
ran always held this page oh is this
skin yeah Oh looks like a honeybee yeah
that's cute that's probably the cutest
one I've seen so far
oh industrial pod
joining game all right who cuz I was
done looking at the battle past anyways
alright
so I'm bug now Ryan let's
land some seeds
man that first game we played in this
mode set me up for failure I was like oh
snap
it's because I was super tanky you know
I even feel that way in like League of
Legends sometimes if the tanks get out
of control
it's scary so hot or no maybe I was just
born to be a tank maybe I need all the
extra life I can get to survive I think
that's that sounds about right
[Music]
that character was good though because
he had his own little self heal his
little refreshing beverage and then they
had the massive machine gun what's
better than that
I mean I definitely do still play some
valor in myself waiting for our players
and we musta lost somebody in the queue
see it up here in the corner
they nerf my character in valor and
though and it actually makes me pretty
sad cipher man it seems like a small
change but it was a big change they like
reduced to slow or took away the slow on
his wires which is unfortunate
just characters like jet and stuff just
dashing in body me all the time
oh I didn't change my up oh oh yeah
okay it's a play the team let's go over
there
I just picked a random place I didn't uh
valor took me a while to get used to and
I was just getting destroyed every time
we win so nice I do plants nowadays
without water
I'm on your team sigh but sure okay so
this feels like maybe Sarah style
thrusters here yeah no three girls gosh
it's so cute okay but we have to be
careful
yeah I definitely think having access
for you
how many feet link and I not okay oh my
gosh I am so squishy though
my party's
he is my crop duster I'm using them that
okay
ah so precious so precious
it's not weird Saunders okay I guess my
teammates gonna follow me which is I
hear stuff over there I still want to be
sneaky I don't think I'm ready to run
into anybody I feel pretty squishy my
health right here at the bottom does not
look like it has very many squares yes
what are these noises I'm really scared
that someone's like looking at me
I see no one
let's move ESU's eruption detected is
cute oh my gosh
[Music]
okay
oh oh no oh no not like this oh I'm
using the wrong button to jump yeah I
need to I'm using the Mickey
okay I'm so confused
and my poison oh crap crap
whoo okay oh my along little lessons in
Russian in progress
okay so these come back pretty quick try
to put a lot of them up like a net
income
you
pollyali are over here
it's like a little mini lucio vibe
oh man there
no be mated offer Alliance one heck no
I'm out of here
essence eruption has subsided I'm just a
little robot
Oh No
at the end
all right we're out I end up a little
robot
to come for me oh no I think this is
coming in this way
[Music]
oh yeah oh no Lucy me there's more
people are amazing I'm just gonna throw
a bunch of plan
one and everything will be fine the
walls are closing in
[Music]
Deathlok field collapsing final essence
condenser to be launched I'm mad about
you don't get help over time there's
something I have to know
and I just wasted it I'm hiding hoping
we'll collect mad homes of concentrated
oh no oh no run little guy run please
I might be able to get this
no little buddy
oh it was hop around and you know I did
get a little bit damaged you know well
that was fun that was very adorable he's
very cute right
Yoshi it robot this robot is adorable I
love love love love and I did bold my
daily let's go let's go okay so let's
get out of here it turns to the lobby
led front alright let's see we have
three more characters we have not tried
but we are over time so we are gonna
have to call it there but that was
really a lot of fun actually
obviously a lot of room for me to grow
and learn and like it better at it but
hopefully at least showcased you know a
wide enough variety of the characters
and what to expect if you are deciding
to pick up crucible which is free to
play and download it now on Steam and I
would assume at some point you'll be
able to download it on amazon.com um and
it is only any right now so stay tuned
everyone else for when it's going live
worldwide I'm assuming that's gonna be
very soon as well so thank you guys so
much for tuning in I had fun I hope you
did too happy Wednesday we're halfway
through the league I know you guys can
make it I believe in you and I hope you
have a great day until next time I'll
see you guys later
[Music]
you